A popular R&B band recently
returned from a successful
three-city tour where
they played to at
least 120,000 people.
My brain immediately says that's
greater than or equal
to 120,000.
If they had an audience of
45,000 in Mesa and another
33,000 in Denver, how
many people attended
their show in Las Vegas?
So let's say Las Vegas, I'll
just use l for Las Vegas.
So the number of people who
attended their show in Las
Vegas plus the number that
attended their show in Mesa,
which is 45,000, plus the number
of people that attended
their show in Denver, which is
33,000-- those are three
cities right there, Las Vegas,
Mesa, and Denver-- that has to
be at least 120,000 people.
Or another way of interpreting
that is greater than or equal
to 120,000.
So to figure out how many people
attended their show in
Las Vegas, we just solve for
l on this inequalty.
So if we simplify this left-hand
side, we get the
number of people in Las Vegas
plus-- what's 45,000 plus
33,000, that is 78,000-- 78,000
is going to be greater
than or equal to 120,000.
Now to isolate the l on the
left-hand side of the
inequality, we can subtract
78,000 from both sides.
So minus 78,000, minus 78,000
on the left-hand side, these
cancel out.
And we're just left with the
number of people who attended
the show in Las Vegas is going
to be greater than or equal to
120,000 minus 78,000.
So 120,000 minus 80,000 is
40,000, and it's going to be
another 2,000.
So the number of people who
attended Las Vegas is going to
be greater than or equal
to 42,000 people.
And we're done, that's it